[Musique]
amoureux des livres le rendez-vous
junior de cette semaine et pour vous
mais l'année ce week-end c'est la nuit
de la lecture
et oui c'est la deuxième édition et ça
c'est roule un peu partout en france
dans les bibliothèques
c'est un rendez vous qui a été lancé par
le ministère de la culture et par chez
nous notamment ça se passe à rambouillet
à la lanterne plus exactement le pôle
culturel de la commune
ça s'appelle la nuit la lecture mais
nous on a décidé de commencer commencé
dès le dd le matin et dès l'après midi
jusque ce soir à 23 heures il y aura un
enchaînement d'événements autour donc de
la lecture atelier d'écriture rencontres
d'auteurs
il y aura une soirée pyjama aussi le
soir une soirée pyjama et oui comme à la
maison quand on fait que les copains les
équipes de la médiathèque propose de
venir en pyjama avec son doudou et son
coussin
la veillée sera assurée par manuel
magali qui est chanteuse musicienne et
raconteuse d'histoires et une stéphane
robin qui lui et glisse guitariste jazz
manouche la soirée pyjama et pour les
enfants de 5 à 10 ans et ça commence à
20h30
alors là m'anime la manifestation de
manière générale est organisée pour les
enfants dès l'âge de 3 ans oui parce que
pour les tout petits c'est un théâtre
d'ombrés chinoises qui est proposé c'est
mener par 3 mio t4 de la lanterne il y a
deux rendez-vous 16h et 17h et toute
allergie nous parler d'ateliers
d'écriture là c'est le premier rendez
vous de la journée totale et c'est à
destination des 8 11 ans à 14h on va
programmer un atelier d'écriture qui
sera animé par béatrice fontanel qui est
une écrivain genèse qui a publié une
quarantaine d'ouvragés des grands
éditeurs gallimard jeunesse albin michel
jeunesse l'école des loisirs
ses thèmes privilégiés c'est la nature
l'histoire les arts alors la soirée
pyjama et en entrée libre sans
inscription le théâtre et l'atelier par
contre d'écriture eux sont sur
inscription direction le site internet
de la lanterne pour ne pas rater le
rendez vous qui vous intéressent